oh this more than that I mean yeah I
know
that's the basic idea anyway so as I've
been talking about this subject for some
time and some of you probably have seen
portions of this talk but there is going
to be new material in it and it's also a
kind of an overview of this work that
I've been doing for the last couple of
years so on I mean that starts with a
pair of semi-definite programs the
primer looks like this linear matrix
inequality with a linear objective
function and he says to do all that do
all I have a PSD matrix y with linear
equality constraints and just the usual
notation is that this curly inequality
means that the B minus a is positive
semi-definite and the dot product of two
matrices is just the stretch number or
test vectors and then you take the inner
product so now I as DP is interesting
okay so and and positive semi
definiteness of course is all principal
sub determinants or non-negative I think
I'm going to skip this slide I mean why
SDP is important obviously linear
programming is a subset of SDP an SDP is
a convex program now I come to the point
that I would like to talk about which is
the duality theory of semi definite
programming so we have this primal dual
pair of SDP is and some things that
happen in linear programming
they are inherited in semi definite
programming so for example on weak
duality comes for free if I have an X
which is feasible here the vibe which is
feasible here then we have this usual
weak duality in equality so so far that
is okay ideally we would like to have a
pair so that the objective values are
equal right so I would like have an
exponent of eyeball where I have equal
objective values now unfortunately this
is where things go wrong so not
everything is inherited from linear
programming
because we could we have some
pathologies for example the supreme
really could be a supreme on earth not
not a maximum the infimum really could
in phenomena a minimum there could even
be a positive duality gap so the optimal
values could be different and of course
that's a bad thing because then we
cannot really certify optimality and of
course if we have a pathological SDP
that could defeat an SDP so other now
I'm going to go through to two very
basic examples the first one is primary
it just has one variable this linear
matrix inequality so if I put everything
on one side that means that this matrix
has to be positive semi-definite right
so then x1 obviously has to be just zero
right because otherwise that determinant
would be negative so um so the supremum
is just 0 and it's attained if I take
the do all the dual is going to be for
the dual variable matrix is why right if
I work things out then it turns out that
the dual is just this problem and in the
dual and trying to infamous divide one
one and the rest and the off diagonal
elements are fixed one and the by 2 2 is
free so then little thought shows that
the white one man could be any positive
tiny little epsilon because I can make
the right to to be large but by 1 1 can
never be equal to 0 right so then this
is a pathological SDP because the do all
is not a paint
very basic example which probably is
seen in every textbook so the other one
other kind of pathology is positive
duality gap so I can take an SDP with
two variables
I try to Supra my's the X tool similar
argument shows that the x2 always has to
be zero because I can put stuff on the
other side and in the x2 was nonzero
then I would have a negative sub
determinant so the x2 always has to be 0
and in the do all have an optimal value
which is 1 right so there's a positive
duality gap so these are the two basic
examples now I would like to understand
what is going on with these two examples
and with others as well so I'm going to
introduce some terminology so I would
like to be I'd like to know when the
system when this positive semi-definite
system is good or bad right some I'm
focusing not just in a particular SDP
but on the system so I'm going to say
that it's badly behaved if there is a C
objective function so that the supremum
of this SDP is finite but the dual
doesn't have a solution with the same
value and that breaks down into several
sub cases
so first up cases that the dual doesn't
obtain or there's a positive gap one
maybe even both right so that's the
definition of a badly behaved semi
definite system and otherwise I call it
well-behaved and I'm also going to call
a slack which is the difference between
the right-hand side and the left-hand
side it's the positive semi-definite
matrix that's kind of the set of hands
[Music]
so that's so far the set up and then for
the motivation of this is that that
these two systems they look kind of very
similar so if we stare at them for a
while then there is some strange
similarity and and what what is that I
mean we can see that for instance one in
the first example there is this kind of
or entity empty diagonal structure right
so there so that is there is this matrix
hidden there is this anti diagonal
structure right and in the second one I
see the exact same thing or something
very similar and so there is this right
hand side matrix and underneath this
anti diagonal structure which shows up
and then the theorem explains why so
this is a semi definite system and I'm
going to assume that the maximum rank
slack matrix in the system isn't of is
of this form right the small identity
and the lots of zeros and I can always
assume that from a theoretical viewpoint
because I can always just apply a
similarity transformation toward the
matrices then the result is that the
system is badly behaved
if and only if there is a certificate
which prove that is badly behaved which
is there is a V linear combination of
the EIS which partitions in this forum
and here the v1 one is or by or so that
matches the size of this identity matrix
the v2 2 is positive semi-definite and
then the last condition is the deranged
space of this one is not a subset of the
range space of the in v2 too so that's
an if and only if characterization of
that behavior and I mean let's let's go
back to the first example to make sure
that checks out I mean in this system x1
always has to be 0 all right so that's
and useless variable and then so
therefore this is the Z matrix that's a
maximum rank slack matrix because that's
the only it's like that makes sense and
then the V is just right and then we can
immediately see that of course the range
space of one is not a subset of three so
I said if and only if characterization
and this takes care of telling when the
system is badly behaved as you stop if
there are any questions can you say a
little bit more about the geometry so
and in the space of A's and B's what
kind of set is it what Co dimension does
it have that's a great question for
algebraic geometers so maybe if somebody
gets interested in it I mean I'm happy
to talk about this I'm you know it's a
zero measure set so we have to be I mean
if I just randomly generate an HTP then
we well behaved on the other hand in
polynomial optimization problems that we
get from the salasi relaxation we do get
these things so you know that's that's a
great question and I'm happy to talk
about it
so then okay so what is missing from
this and this is where elementary row
operations come into the picture and I
said that might answer some of some of
Barron's question so so if I want to
convince someone that the system is
badly behaved then I can show that okay
here is the Z and the V right so then
please believe me that my system is
badly behaved on the other hand I mean
the Z and V they say that okay well
therefore that exists a bad objective
function for which the primal is finite
but the dual doesn't have a matching
solution she says that that exists but
it doesn't give me the C right and on
the other hand it's not a polynomial
time or easy to verify proof which is
suppose I tell you that okay here is the
Z and the V and believe me that this
system is badly behaved but why should
you believe me because this there is
this theorem which is five pages long
and then if you read the proof of the
theorem then you can believe me that the
Z and we really proved the bad behavior
right but I want something more natural
than that so the idea that came up is
that suppose how do I prove just a basic
linear system of equations is infeasible
but I do elementary row operations and I
create a row echelon form which says
that 0 X is equal to 1 and after that I
don't have to say that my system implies
0 X equal to 1 therefore that is this
complicated theorem and believe me that
it's invisible I mean you know so I
would like to borrow ideas from the row
echelon form and the that's where
reformulations come in so this is the
system and I'm going to do some of the
following operations so I can apply a
rotation to all matrices there it is an
invertible matrix so I replace the AI by
V transpose HIV and the B by B transpose
B what I can translate the B by a linear
combination of the e is or I can change
an AI to linear combinations
of the ages or that can switch AI and AJ
right these are very natural operations
and of course it doesn't they don't
change the behavior of the system right
I mean it's just kind of an elector
stone is just translating the spectra
he'd run right so that doesn't do
anything and these are invertible
operations so you know they don't affect
the behavior of the system and if I do
choose the V carefully then they also
keep the maximum rank slack in the same
shape in that identity and lots of zeros
okay so on and then here's the result
about reformulating that system so it's
badly behaved if and only if it has a
reformation of this form where Z is the
maximum slack so I just normalize the
system so that that became the
right-hand side and these matrices are
linearly independent meaning that if I
take a linear combination and I get the
zero then the coefficients must be 0 and
the HN has to be positive semi-definite
so I claim that if you if the system is
in this normal form it's kind of like a
row echelon form right it's very easy to
convince somebody that this is badly
behaved right and I can prove it in like
in three lines so I will do it so what
do I prove that a system in this
particular shape is badly behaved and
this might actually give some hints
about how to go about codimension and
things like that
so suppose that X is a feasible solution
right and suppose that the corresponding
slack is s so the S is the Z minus the
summation X I I yeah it's right then I
know that the last n minus r columns of
s must be 0 right because they have a
PSD matrix which is nonzero somewhere
here right then I take the convex
combination of that with this Z and I
get a bigger rank matrix right so that
shouldn't be so these columns have to be
0 so therefore by the linear
independence condition the XK plus 1
through X M they also have to be all 0
right they have those sort so basically
the XK plus 1 through X M they are like
used
variables which are always your own so
that were if I take this trivial
objective function minus X and I've
Supra my's it is going to be zero
for obvious reasons because the X M is
always zero right so I have an objective
function which is a finite optimal value
over this system and at the same time
there is no dual solution with the same
value that's another two lines of proof
which so essentially we we brought this
into a normal form which proves easily
without referring to any kind of
complicated theorem that the system is
badly behaved it's kind of like a you're
watching on form of our system okay so
in an example so before the formulation
it looks like this we can we tell that
this is well behaved or badly behaved
and probably not right be a challenge so
to speak after reformulate it looks like
this which is a lot sparse or of course
but sparse it is not so much the point
but but the point is that in this system
it's easy to see that the X 3 and X 4
are always 0 so that gives me a trivial
objective function with a finite and
actually zero value ok the corollary is
like we can do a similarly formulation
for well-behaved systems and may I ask
this question is this semi definite
system well-behaved or badly behaved
it's an NP intercept when P right and
what's the certificate for that the
certificate is I can give you this
normal forum right and and then from the
normal forum you can see very easily
that it's badly behaved or well behaved
and then to accompany the normal form I
have to give you the elementary row
operations which produced it and the
similarity transformation so it's a it's
kind of a nice very simple proof and
yeah so that's the certificate and
there's a corollary that if it's well
behaved
for every see which is a finite
objective value I can produce a dual
solution which is block diagonal which
is a useful thing to so that's it about
belly beer stuff are there any questions
I should stop here and this just to be
short when we do the low reduction in
the inequality it's clear what yes yes
it's very clear so but the catch there
is that unfortunately we don't know how
to compute the Z and the V right I mean
I'm going to talk about that a bit more
but once I do have the Z and the V it's
completely trivial to produce the row
operations it's almost the same thing as
as block Gaussian elimination matrices
right okay so how about how about any
feasibility that's the joint work with
mink Willy who was my PhD student couple
years ago so now this is a semi definite
system in equality constraint one VI dot
X equal to bi explosive semi definite I
mean this used to be VY but 9x just two
and they are symmetric matrices there's
a dot product not what I want to do I
want to prove infeasibility right how do
I prove that this system is infeasible
there's a certain kind of Farkas lemma
for SDP which says that there is this
alternative system if there is a linear
combinations of the EIS which is pH D
and the summation Y idea is negative one
it's called if alternative system then I
know that the so okay so I have these
two two alternatives so if this is
feasible then this original system is
infeasible right so one implies two and
usually I ask this question that you
know and then the proof of this is very
simple it's like one line it's the same
thing as in
very similar to the proof for cash
llamas use one as in linear programming
now the other direction has very long
proof because that's not even true so in
other words this alternative system is
not an exact certificate of in
feasibility so there exists semi
definite systems which are infeasible
but alternative system is always so
infeasible so sometimes sometimes we
cannot certify the in feasibility yeah
now there are exact certificates only
feasible so they exist so the one word
that was was present by Ramana in 1995
so that was the first such a certificate
of in feasibility and then and then lit
the respond by clapping schweighöfer
which the algebraic geometry people
would probably know best here and then
there are works on facial reduction
which was all originally invented by
Baldwin and work with in 1981 and then
certificate of invisibility was produced
by Avakian
muramatsu and also this work by ramon xi
uncial and work of it's connected from
Ana's the world to reduction alright so
there so exact certificates of
invisibility exist however I mean
they're not what that's simple right so
for instance if you read Romano's do all
I don't know how many of you are
familiar with that but you really have
to absorb the fact that he rides done
essentially n copies of the original
system and they connects them with these
linear matrix inequality s but the UI's
and the w i's are extra variables and
then I mean I mean when I first saw it
it was kind of difficult to wrap my head
around that what are these you guys and
W guys doing there okay so so they exist
but you would like to produce something
simpler than them so I would like to
produce something which is an exact
certificate of infeasible
the witch is almost as simple as for
question and mom so let's see how to do
that so the example that we played with
is this very basic infeasible SDP now
how do I prove that this is infeasible
suppose X is feasible then the first
equation says that X 1 1 is equal to 0
right now by positive semi definiteness
the first row and column of the X also
has to be 0 right after that the second
equation said that X 2 2 is equal to
negative 1 right away I have a
contradiction right so this system is is
totally trivially infeasible um ok so is
this very special the answer it is not
very special so the main idea is that we
are going to find such a structure in
every infeasible SDP but of course that
structure is not going to be there just
for free we have to do our elementary
row operations and so three formulations
come back again so reformulation is I do
elementary row operations on these
equations and I can also do similarity
transformations and then that's all we
do and of course one comes from Gaussian
elimination
and that of course the deformations
preserve visibility or infeasible
now some basically in your algebra so if
I see an equation like that when X is
positive semi-definite question is what
does this say about the X right so then
identity lots of zeros and dot X is
equal to zero and X is positive
semi-definite what does it say about the
X well of course what it says about the
X is that the sum of these diagonal
elements must be zero right see there
for every one of them has to be zero and
by positive semi definiteness those rows
and columns have to be zero right
so therefore that means that the X
actually looks like that so that's the
basic linear algebra and then so here's
the theorem theorem says the following
so the P is infeasible if and only if it
has a reformulation in a certain shape
and a certain shape is like this I have
K plus 1 equations which are special
right and there is some other stuff
there the dot dot dot means that there
are some other equations which are
actually totally irrelevant because this
first k plus 1 were already going to
prove in feasibility and these special
equations look like the e 1 prime looks
like there's a small identity and a lots
of 0s right so the e 2 prime looks like
there is or one rows and columns so the
first R 1 rows and columns can have
arbitrary stuff there so the crosses
mean that you can have anything there
and after that there is a small identity
matrix and then some more zeros and then
in general the AI prime looks like in
the first or 1 plus plus or I minus 1
rows and columns I can have arbitrary
stuff right that doesn't count and then
have a little identity there and then I
have zeros here right so that's the
statement that P is infeasible if and
only if I can put this into the if I can
put it into this particular shape but
the AI Prime's have that particular form
right so now the question is why is this
as simple as the elementary
I mean the row echelon form is not much
more difficult because I can prove that
this particular system is infeasible and
I can prove that in like two lines right
so how do I do that
suppose that X is feasible right the
first equation says that a one prime dot
X is equal to zero right so now even
prime dot X is equal to zero that proves
that the first or one rows and columns
of X are 0 right so if that's the case
then I can go to the second equation
which says that e 2 prime dot X is equal
to 0 and that's going to wipe out the
next or 2 rows and columns of X right
and I keep going like that right so I
keep going in and then I group that the
first or 1 plus by plus or Kia rows and
columns of X are 0 I'm saying that the
first so many row is all 0 but of course
then I come to the k plus first equation
right this is the a couple ek plus 1
prime was has a special form that I get
that ek plus 1 prime dot X is
non-negative
all right but on the other hand the
equation says that it's equal to
negative 1 so that's obviously
impossible right so so that's the I'm
it's not as simple as the proof that the
row echelon form proves in feasibility
but it's not much more complicated so
it's kind of as simple as we can make
that you stop here and
questions no I mean I may have more
stuff to say so the talk is not over in
just an intermediate stop okay so okay
so back to the example so the example is
already in that form I don't even have
to do anything right so here the a1
prime is is this right so then there is
this small identity matrix and both
those zeros the second matrix I have
some arbitrary stuff in the first one
row and one colon and there's a small
identity here and then there's the minus
one so the proof outline I mean how
difficult is this proof it's about the
page and a half so it's really not
complicated it's very elementary and the
alternative is that there is a
traditional Fisher reduction algorithm
which is goes back to Boorman and Bach
awaits the one by walking Moodle and so
that's the easier that we can fit all of
it and then we can actually get this
reload or we can do it independently ok
so then the corollary is that now now we
get to this point that the semi definite
feasibility is in NP intercept quantity
in the real number model of computing
right so that that's the proved that's
the result that was stated and proved
first by Ramana but now we have a
simpler proof now if I want to show that
something is feasible the system is
feasible I just show you an X right you
can plug in then you can check that it's
actually feasible now if I want to prove
that the system is not feasible that
means that feasibility is in Co NP then
I can show you the reformulated system
that nice semi definite epsilon form
right and it's trivially infeasible and
Ike I have to convince you that I really
got the system from the original system
and hardware convinced you but I show
you the similarity transformations which
I can just pack it into one matrix and I
can show you the elementary row
operations
which also come packaged into one matrix
right see if I give you these two
matrices accompanied by the semi
definite epsilon form system then that's
completely convincing that this system
is increased so basically two matrices
verify you feasibility okay so then can
I keep going so then question is that I
get asked a lot so is this just theory
right okay so you can prove these nice
beef formulations and you're saying that
this is something like the row echelon
form but then of course what a turn-on
for me can compute that right by MATLAB
work
okay so on the only other hand I cannot
really say that we can compute this
Reformation so easily because in in
order to do that in general you would
have to solve SDP is in exact arithmetic
right so that part is not as nice as in
basically in the rapture
however the mathematicians apology right
so the sexual use work or something so
so one application is that suppose I
want to generate want to write down an
infeasible system of me an infeasible
SDP right so how do I do that when I
tear em says that every infeasible SDP
can be put into this special form right
if I want to write down an infeasible
SDP then how can I do that well I can
generate any infeasible SDP right
because I can write down an SDP in this
trivial form in this epsilon form right
and after that I can just mess it up
right I can do some elementary row
operations and some rotations and this
way I'm going to get every infeasible
semi-definite system right so the
analogy that I came up with that at some
point suppose I want to create an
infeasible in
system of equations right so how can I
do that I can say that well I ride on a
system which is ax equal to B 0 X equal
to 1 right and I can just mess it up
doing some elementary row operations and
this way actually I get every infeasible
linear system of equations so it's a
good way to actually like create an exam
question in linear algebra right let me
just write down a system like that and
then mess it up and then the students
can figure it out right so now a very
similar result applies to 2's DPS so so
we can actually generate some nice
problem libraries so what we did is we
did min quickly so we generated a
problem library of infeasible and the
weakly infeasible as DP is not the
weakly infeasible ones are the
particularly nasty ones because the
distance of that affine subspace to the
semi definite cone is 0 even though they
don't intersect so they are numerically
really nasty and then that actually
generated some interest and there's some
follow-up work by what our Yein and
colleagues and then by others who is
solving these problems so that was the
first application now the second
application is is see you might wonder
ok so we can put any infeasible SDP into
this particular epsilon form right but
what if I have an SDP which is
infeasible and actually I don't have to
do anything at all because it's already
in that special form right so could that
happen and and the surprising fact is
that it does happen sometimes right I
mean not not every time but a lot of the
times it happens so on so sometimes we
have s DPS which are already in that
special form and that's we have we have
this preprocessor which we call sieve as
DP for various reasons because the
structure that it creates looks like a
sieve so I show you an example so so
this is a
and SDP which comes from a polynomial
optimization problem
so what we are picturing here is that we
are picturing the e eyes right so the e
I'm it is as we stretch out this vectors
right so then then I get something like
this the the the blue is the blue and
the red is nonzero and the white is zero
so before we pre-process it looks like
this and after we pre-process it looks
like this right so sometimes this very
silly method to detect infeasibility or
to reduce an SDP it works amazingly
right and not every time of course I
mean it's not you know this doesn't
happen all the time but it does happen
and so I have run pretty fast so I looks
like there will be time for questions ok
so the question is can we apply this
methodology to understand other
pathologies in some indefinite programs
and the answer is yes so there is some
promising starts for instance to
understand positive duality gaps the
theorem is this so positive duality gaps
when the see the primal has a positive
value of let's say one the dual has a
value of two that was a particularly
nasty and they are not all that well
understood either so there is a recent
result which says that suppose it m is
equal to 2 right so we have two
variables and that doesn't look like
it's a very impressive result because I
mean why not m equal to 3 or something
like that right but the fact is that
when M is equal to 1 then one can prove
that easily that there is no duality gap
that's live like the neck sir science
right
for m equal to 2 this hasn't been known
until very recently what is the
characterization for m equal to 2 so
when m equal to 2 what i can do is i can
say that there is a positive gap if and
only if i can reformulate my SDP into
this form I have two variables and what
we have is elaborate we have lots of 0s
here right empty spaces stand for 0s we
have a lambda which is the positive
definite matrix we have an M which is a
mu zero matrix and this is an identity
and zeros on the
there is the negative identity er which
might be an empty matrix or the S is
greater or equal than zero so we have
some understanding of positive duality
gaps as well so there are some papers
here and one interesting point of this
is that the mathematics actually gets
very very simple towards the end right
so at the beginning started with some
relatively heavy convex analysis and
then going down the list it really
became were like undergraduate level I
mean I'm seriously so it's up by the end
this this this paper is really kind
written advanced undergraduate level and
illusion is that there are all these
pathologies we can write down this
combinatorial type characterizations and
then reformulations come into the
picture elementary row operations and
simulated transformations and then
simply certificate of infeasibility
we can generate all infeasible SDPs
and there's some practical uses problem
libraries and they can do pre-processing
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so you took waka for Lulu and then you
so in their prime fellas watch for the
speaking so ha what is that idea you
just say it's similar to yours oh it's
some I mean I if I don't know it's like
homotopy or something like that I mean
I'm not totally familiar with with what
kind of algorithm they are using I
honestly I don't know I'm the right now
I don't think I'm the right answer to
the right person to answer that question
so yeah yes I mean they regenerated this
problem library and they were able to
recognize not just in feasibility but
week in feasibility of those instances
and of course I'm I mean I don't think
that that cannot work every time is if
you do floating-point operations so but
but for some instances it did work
I have a question so it suppose that you
have a guru semi definite programming
depending on a parameter you might think
of the parameters being performance it's
some engineering problem
and so then if we insist on high
performance it's infeasible we insist on
less performance it becomes feasible so
if you take your your method you have a
sieve I guess what can you have an
ordinal form is it does it tolerate a
parameter in some magical way or would
one just have to step the parameter down
I guess it depends how the parameter
shows up I mean I mean if the I mean I
would say the parameter is very simple
then let's say one of the e eyes looks
like an AI Zi bar plus lambda times AI
double bar then it might be might be
possible to do this symbolically and I
guess it depends how the parameter shows
out
that's a problem yeah I mean the whole
what is the parameter show up that's a
question I'm happy to look into it if
you think that the algorithm for this
one is not fully time but state SDP
software is actually volatile right well
I mean the depth comes a lot a lot of
qualifications I mean as the SD as it is
overly polynomial time that means that
if you have a primal strictly feasible
point and the do obstacle feasible point
then in polynomial time we can reduce
the duality gap by half right but if
those the X and the Z X and divide did
one they are not given then then we
don't know I mean even as DP feasibility
is not known to be so is it possible
that by I run some somepony time
algorithm and then check if the time
exceeded and then declared something
like it is aboard
somebody here it happens
because I mean what is what is pilita
Papa Li time is already depends on
what's of lots of parameters and then
there are the constants they are to
start with right and then the speed of
convergence and all those things so I
mean I think the answer is more I mean
the absolute expert on this would be Jim
Brannigan obviously my answer is no so
it just doesn't work like that it's just
not no because you don't have a piece
you can't have a certificate being a
point because the point you get they can
no X been double exponentially in size
so they're not they're not bounded in
bitly for example so the Turing machine
is out at a possibility in the real
number bottle yeah and so you're allowed
infinite precision so then yeah you do
have a feasibility checks in there
there's polynomial time yeah I was just
gonna say what Jim said this way go
ahead but you know when you said you
don't know whether it's TP disabilities
and P we don't even know if it's an end
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
each degree might do a lot but we don't
know this well that's one of the
problems you know we we don't know a
compact way of representing in the
Turing machine a certificate to verify
that second certificates come up with
ordering or domain of the domain of the
data dimension there are examples where
the solution public actually and of
course they're also irrational which
sometimes you can switch
you know you're odd what your points oh
yeah I said you could hope that you
could write down the system you could
represent the coordinates of the
solution as roots of a polynomial then
you'd be able to apply some decision
method for polynomials to decide whether
or not it's feasible but then the lungs
and showed that the degrees of the
polynomials you would need to do that
throughout to make it out of reach
because I'm if I give you an SDP with
integer entries right then then of
course the answer is going to be yes or
no is it feasible or not but but what
but to get there you have to go through
an enormous amount of mass and yeah a
challenge I mean they would say it right
thank you very much
[Applause]